[موسيقى]
في البدايه كان النمط العمل له علاقه في
التعبيريه التجريديه احيانا ينزح قليلا
نحو التجريد احيانا ينزح قليل نحو التعبير
لكن اول تحول في تجربتي حدث بعد رحيل
والدتي
كان خوفي الاكبر انه افقدها وانا ما اقدر
اودعها فاول عمل اشتغلت تشخيص كان
لوالدتي
بدات اعمل على استعاده ذاكره الحنين من
الحواري حواري الفرات الى الوجوه الغائبه
الى ناس احنا فقدناه وما عاد في امكانيه
لاستعادتهم الا عبر اللوحه
بعد ذلك وبدات اقارب مسارات لها علاقه في
البعد العاطفي في الحب في قوه الحياه في
البعد هذا النابض اليومي
بعد ما حدث في سوريا يعني 2011 يعني هذه
الماساه وتحولت الشخوص ايضا الى شخوص
متشضيه بدا درامي ماساوي ربما
يدخل في نسيج اللوحه
لاول مره ومن غير اي معرفه مسلقه طبعا انه
لماذا يعني بدات ارسم المسيح هو كانت يعني
رحله مفتوحه داخل الذات الانسانيه
العين اصبحت تحدق في الداخل
دائما مثل ما حبر تريله امي في الاعمال
ودائما تلمح صوره المسيح
[موسيقى]
الاعمال العظيمه
وليست المواهب العظيمه من هون ينبغي
الانسان الى الروح لانها بتقديره الخلاص
الوحيد من سبيل الوحيد
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات